CBS ran the iconic yet occasionally controversial
"Big Bang Theory" from September 2007
to the show's conclusion in May 2019. Instead of
focusing on families or co-workers, the series put
the spotlight on folks that rarely get a say in
most big-budget productions: nerds. In doing so,
"Big Bang" made it cool to be a geek and embrace
whatever aspects of science, pop culture,
and general entertainment spoke to you via
an ensemble cast of unforgettable characters.
One of those aforementioned
nerds was Howard Wolowitz,
the horniest and creepiest of the bright friends.
While he often made inappropriate advances toward
the females around him, he did eventually find
love. He settled down with an addition to the
cast named Bernadette, played by Melissa Rauch.
Throughout many seasons, we got to know Bernadette
quite well. As we saw time and time again on "The
Big Bang Theory," Bernadette was a good friend,
spouse, scientist, and mother. However, there was
one major negative element about her personality
that was never shy about rearing its ugly head.
At her core, Bernadette was a mild-mannered,
kind woman who wanted to see those around
her live their best lives just as
much as she wanted to do so herself.
She didn't always display these attributes,
though, especially when she found herself
in competitive situations, no matter
how inconsequential. She'd transform
into a determined and unapologetically
harsh person — often slinging insults
left and right regardless as to who was around
her. Even Howard wasn't immune to her wrath,
finding himself on the receiving end of his wife's
rage more times than he surely wanted to be.
Despite all of this, Bernadette's short fuse
didn't always end up putting just her friends
in her crosshairs. She could also use her fiery
spirit in such a way that would actually protect
the people she cares about, driving off anyone who
unjustly dared disrespect them in front of her.
She shows no hesitation when standing up for
Howard and even defends Stuart from a rival
comic book store owner's bullying. Given her
presentation as a quiet, easy-going young lady,
they never see it coming, hence the
hilarity of these particular scenes.
When provoked, Bernadette could become a
terrifying person that didn't discriminate
when it came to verbally attacking
other people. This is obviously
not the best character trait to have, but
it's aided by the fact that she tends to
use it in defense of the ones she loves
more often than not. It only ever really
became a problem when her loved ones
were on the wrong side of her scorn.
A feisty attitude is one thing. It's another thing
entirely to become obsessive to the point
where you demean the person you love most
in the world. And that was something
Bernadette was not afraid of doing.
If there were a single episode that best
encapsulated Bernadette's competitive nature,
it would be Season 12, Episode 9, "The Citation
Negation." This episode sees Howard and Raj
becoming obsessed with the video game sensation
"Fortnite." Bernadette wants to get in on the fun,
but there's just one problem — she's not
very good at the game. She enlists the help
of Denise to teach her the ways of "Fortnite,"
but no matter how much she practices, she still
can't get better than her husband. When
Howard kills Bernadette's character quickly,
she responds with an obviously embarrassed jab.
"Howard?"
"What?"
"I make more money than you!"
The funny thing is that Howard never made fun
of her for being bad at "Fortnite" He also had
no problem letting her play for a little bit
to see what the game was like for herself.
How nice. Her competitive side
wouldn't allow Howard and Raj
to have a fun activity for the two of them
to share. She had to become the best at it,
and when she failed, she had to find another way
to demonstrate her superiority over her husband.
Granted, we're probably looking too deeply
into this personality trait. We know it's all
meant for laughs. However, regardless of how you
feel about Bernadette, you have to admit Melissa
Rauch's performance is second-to-none, even if
it made the character a bit unlikeable at times.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.